right hello everyone welcome to today's
midday briefing online and live on ebs
we are today wednesday the 1st of
september
good luck to all the kids
who are going back to school to all the
teachers and all to all the parents
who are going to have to deal with this
once again
we don't have any announcements today
but let me remind you that an informal
meeting of you defense ministers is
taking place today and tomorrow in
bordeaux slovenia hosted by the
slovenian presidency and chaired by
representative vice president joseph
bohel
commissioner
will also participate
during the two days eu defense ministers
will have a discussion on the strategic
compass
then ministers will focus on the current
situation afghanistan as well as
developments in eu operational
activities in particular in the sahel
libya mozambique and the western balkans
the meeting will conclude with a working
lunch together with nato and the u.n on
common geostrategic challenges
and opportunities and the press
conference with the slovenian defense
minister and the higher representative
vice president
is tentatively
scheduled for tomorrow at 3 30
brussels time as usual the press
conference will be broadcast
on ebs
that is all uh from our side today so
let us move to your questions
any questions
for us today
[Music]
attacks
against saudi arabia
hi peter
the houthi are targeting
the saudi arabia facilities civilian
facilities almost every day or they are
trying every day
they hit civilian facilities for example
two days before they hit a civilian
airplane
what is the european union reaction
towards this
uh unlimited attacks from the houthi
against the civilian attack civilian
facilities
all this despite the peace offers on the
table
second
when
will the european union
goes beyond its let's say soft approach
towards these militia because this is
these militia are the only part
or the only party
who are still refusing
the
peace of the weather
forward by
present by the united states
united nation regional actors let's like
like saudi arabia they are the only one
who are uh opposing
multiple offers
to to to sit to the table thank you very
much peter thank you eric
peter thank you good afternoon
indeed we have received
reports and we have seen reports of
increased military activity uh in the
area of marib in in yemen and this past
week has also seen the houthi attacks on
a military base in al-anat and against
abha international airport in saudi
arabia which led to civilian casualties
and we as european union we condemn
these cross-border attacks that endanger
civil aviation deep in regional
insecurity and they undermine efforts to
end the yemeni crisis and the yemeni
conflict and these cross-border attacks
have to stop so this is on the first
part of your question about the use
reaction the european union feels very
strongly and we've been very vocal on
this uh for for some time already that
there can be only a political solution
to the crisis in yemen and that's why we
keep calling on all the parties to this
conflict to seize hostilities and to
engage constructively with the u.n
special envoy uan is in the lead on this
uh on these efforts to find the
political solution to the crisis we
support the u.n efforts very strongly
and the second part of your question or
the answer
the answer to your second question is
when will the eu change its soft
approach the eu use approach is always
engagement always arguing for political
solution
the calls on the parties are not
delivered only through statements and
answers like these but they are
delivered also in direct contact with
our regional partners and with the
actors who have influence on on actors
on the ground who are part of the
conflict such as the houthis so this uh
engagement is multi-layer engagement and
we keep exercising all the efforts we
can in order to bring this message home
and to argue and to support all the
efforts in favor of political solution
of the yemeni crisis because in the end
the crisis can be solved only by yemenis
in a process which is agreed by the
yemenis
thank you very much
are there other questions on this topic
for
peter
eric you have your hand raised i don't
know if it's on this
no okay you've on raise it very good any
other foreign related questions yes
please
uh khaled amir farooqi from jio
television news pakistan
the interior minister's declaration
about refugees it seems that not a
single refugee welcome to europe not a
single
european country is going to accept
austria particularly completely rejected
what is your position on refugees and
they also suggested that neighboring
countries
will be helped
to established refugee reception centers
thank you you're coming
yes thank you very much if you um allow
we will come back to that issue because
it's not a question for peter it's more
question for adelberg although you're
absolutely right it is
obviously uh very much foreign policy
related as well so before we move on to
that are there any other questions for
peter
on
international affairs
[Music]
you have your hand raised so i don't
know if it's on international affairs
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
any other questions on foreign affairs
for peter
[Music]
that is not the case thank you peter so
adelberg if you can come and discuss
with us the results
of yesterday's
justice and home affairs meeting
and in particular the question on
refugees from afghanistan
thank you very much and before
addressing that question maybe i can
just
compliment what you were saying eric
about the different activities of of
members of the college relating to the
situation in afghanistan by mentioning
by also referring to the trip of
commissioner johansson to the united
states on monday and which continues in
fact right now where commissioner
johansson has also met with a number of
uh high-level officials from the united
nations and she's also been in direct
contact with philippa grandi the u.n
high commissioner for refugees also to
discuss uh that situation so it's also
um
there are also high level contacts on on
on that level specifically on the home
affairs related issues now when it comes
to the uh the statement of uh of home
affairs ministers um first of all i
would i would say that we very much uh
welcome this uh this statement it is
something also that commissioner
johansson expressed yesterday at the
press conference it is a clear sign that
member states are able to
adopt a common approach on
on
migration issues
and it is also a comprehensive approach
uh that the uh that ministers are um are
presenting uh where the eu in
cooperation with the international
community um is is able to um respond to
the developments in afghanistan
in
as as they unfold in a coordinated
way
now the
it is clear that the immediate
priorities uh are as also commissioner
johansson expressed humanitarian
assistance in afghanistan
as well as operational and financial
assistance to reinforce the protection
capacity of the countries in the region
which would then be the first affected
by um by any movements of people out of
afghanistan to seek refuge however i
i would also like to recall that the
commissioner announced that the
commission will urgently organize a
high-level resettlement forum and that
resettlement is also a an extremely
important part of
of our response it is also something
that
the president referred to after
the g7 meeting it is something that
needs to be done
by the international community
countries that have engaged
in afghanistan need to
need to all
participate however from the from the
commission side um we will also make a
specific effort on on this issue and
organize this high level resettlement
forum
so it is it is a comprehensive response
which doesn't focus exclusively on uh on
certain aspects but which takes into
account the entirety of the needs um to
respond to this situation
thank you
any other questions on this issue
for him
or on other home affairs issues
yes please
uh yes my name is mateusz kevos has
finished here doctor
i have seen
different amounts of money that might be
reserved for
the regions around afghanistan by the
european uh union uh
is this is there already um an amount uh
that you think of to support these
neighboring countries is this something
that is up to the commission or is it
the member states who have to decide on
this
so this is not really a question on the
justice and home affairs meeting
yesterday strictly speaking although i
perfectly understand why you are making
a legitimate um link with it
i will call anna on this on this issue
and welcome back thank you
so many thanks for the question i'm
afraid that um i don't think we're at
the stage uh able to go into our figures
i think that you know what we can very
clearly say is that um the eu will of
course continue supporting um its
partners to protect uh refugees and
people in need of international
protection and supporting of course um
host uh countries and communities um and
of course this also would include um you
know supporting uh to build economic
opportunities in particular for uh youth
and addressing of course root causes of
the irregular migration as well of
course as reinforcing our partner
country's capacities on border
management and governance including of
course
in particular border management
you are very well aware that um under
the indicki so the new uh financing
instruments that will be the main
financing instrument for external um
cooperation with our partner countries
there's an an indicative 10 percent of
its overall budget of close to 80
billion euros that would um
help us support partner countries in
specifically in the field of migration
but again programming under indicate is
ongoing and at this stage we are not in
a position to um to go into figures but
of course needless to say that um this
uh you know the the conditions on the
ground and the specific needs of uh
partner countries would be uh taken into
account and i think that this is also a
message that was very clearly passed by
commissioner johansson
yesterday as well
thank you very much
any other questions for anna while she
is on the podium
on
development date in particular
or international partnerships no
thank you anna any other questions for
us today
yes
i have follow-up question that
uh
this debacle
and disastrous consequences of iran war
when americans europeans and different
countries went there they did not
consult a single country neighboring
countries and now they have to
host
millions of refugees they had already
four million refugees and europe is not
really accepting single one do you think
this is fair policy of european union
look i think we have said uh
a lot on all the efforts that we are
making
as a consequence of a crisis which
i remind you is absolutely not generated
in any way by the european union
you have seen the statements that we
have made that are extremely clear
um including from the president of the
european commission
on
the fact that we have a duty to help
those who are in danger
in particular
women and
and young girls
whose opportunities
would be curtailed in particular
journalists in particular
female judges and and lawyers etc etc
and first secondly we have said
that we are proactively
organizing meetings in order to assess
the situation
and
find agreements on um on on
numbers of refugees that can that can be
accepted in europe and thirdly of course
we are reflecting on how to support both
uh
the afghan how to support the afghan
people both in the country and abroad so
i think that everything that could be
said on this has been said of course the
situation will continue to develop and
as we have announcements to make we will
certainly
we will certainly inform you
all right
i will now close
this chapter related to
the crisis in afghanistan in foreign
relations in general
and we'll move on to other issues and
maria had a question
maria
hello i hope you can hear me
i would like to come back to the
question i had yesterday for the
commission about the oil spill
coming from syria towards cyprus do you
have any news any update on that thank
you thank you question for tim
hey maria
so uh yeah we we've seen the situation
as badass mentioned to you yesterday and
obviously very concerned about the
potentially serious environmental
impacts um which could come from this
oil spill from a refinery in the syrian
town of benis
we understand that the cypriot
authorities are
following this closely and are ready to
act
cyprus has requested technical
assistance from the european maritime
safety agency through the eu civil
protection mechanism
and an oil recovery vessel from the
agency has been offered to cyprus and
that's currently being mobilized in the
relevancies
the commission would further recommend
that the relevant countries activate the
existing collaboration framework to
respond to oil pollution in the
mediterranean region which comes under
the barcelona convention
and specifically there's a protocol
which concerns preventing pollution from
ships and cases of emergency combating
pollution of the mediterranean sea so
that's what i can say for now on this
issue
thank you very much
any other questions for tim today
on the
energy or environment portfolio
no
any other issues
yes
on polish recovery and resilience plan
uh exactly a month ago the deadline
agreed by european commission and the
push government
on
of assessment of the of the polish
project uh did pass
and
i'm
well aware about the criteria of
assessment so on but my question is
whether the european commercial
commission or poland has asked for the
formal extension of the uh of the of the
finalization of the assessment of the
polish plan thank you
thank you too much there is absolutely
nothing new that i can add compared to
all the previous statements
on this work on the
on the plan continues
there are contacts between of course
the commission and the polish
authorities on the
on the plan that is all that i can say
on this
any other questions for us today
yes please
in the autumn the support for strict
corona measures differs vastly among eu
citizens and according to a new poll
there is a lot of skepticism about the
motivation behind the lockdown in
countries like bulgaria poland and
france
and i was wondering what are the plans
of the commission to unite the people of
europe in the fight against the pandemic
wow
now that is the most open question that
i've had in a very very long time
the plan that the commission has had now
for a very very long time
um has been to ensure
the availability in sufficient
quantities
of
safe and efficacious vaccines
to ensure that the people of europe can
be protected from the virus
and we have been um
extremely focused as you know on
delivering on this plan
and we are now at a stage where i think
it is
very clear to anyone who wants to look
at the evidence
that
the
vaccination campaigns
are providing
a significant degree of safety for
europeans
and therefore
of course we are continuing to cooperate
with countries in particular those where
there is a significant issue of vaccine
hesitancy in terms of informing
the public on the
advantages of
becoming vaccinated and we reiterate on
a very regular basis the call for people
to be uh to be vaccinated so i think
that our efforts have been very clear
for for all to see i think that the
successes
are there but at the same time we
acknowledge
like i think all public authorities that
the efforts must continue
we need to increase the vaccination rate
in particular in those countries where
it is low and we need to continue to
monitor the situation and adapt our
strategy as the epidemiological
situation evolves
thank you very much
any other questions for us on the health
theme
catherine
oops hi eric okay hi eric um
you know somebody asked the question
yesterday about uh the situation about
uneven vaccination across the eu
and um i mean we see very very good
rates and you know it's fantastic to see
how high the rate of vaccination is in
for example ireland
but
uh
you know we also see
the figures for romania and bulgarian
and and yet ireland we here
bought some vaccines from romania a
country that's under vaccinated so
have you got any specific idea of why
romania is not using those vaccines that
it had access to
and
in yesterday's press release uh
commissioner clerici said we will
continue to support those countries that
are
continuing to face challenges so could
you be a bit more specific
and maybe address it in
uh you know in this with a specific
example why is romania selling its
vaccines to ireland when it's so under
vaccinated and ireland is doing
relatively well thank you
thank you catherine for your question
well the first thing i would ask you to
do is to ask
those two countries
to
explain the transactions that took place
between them we are not privy to all of
the individual
discussions that take place between
member states let me just remind you
that vaccines have a shelf life
and therefore
it's obvious that there is an interest
for member states
to ensure
that
vaccines that have that are available in
a country
are used or can be used elsewhere and
this is something that i think we all
have to encourage
in order to ensure that
we maximize the benefits from the
vaccines but for the rest i would ask
you to contact the countries concerned
catherine follow up
so i'm i'm quoting from the commissioner
kiryakiris who said that the eu will
continue to support those countries well
the vaccines has arrived what
specifically does this
sort of support is she referring to
thank you catherine this is a question
we've had uh quite a few times already
and we've said that we are supporting
member states where there are
issues of vaccine hesitancy to
communicate to the public in order to
to reinforce the message on the fact
that vaccines that have been approved
for use within the european union are
safe and efficacious and provide
therefore real benefits for the health
of citizens
and
therefore encourage them to become
vaccinated but let me remind you that
the commission's primary responsibility
is to deliver the vaccines to the member
states vaccination efforts and
vaccination campaigns
are and remain the responsibility
of the national authorities this is
simply
a question of
of a national prerogative
based on the treaties and the
competences of member states
any other questions for us on health
related issues
yes please
yes thanks the commission yesterday
announced that 70 percent of adult
citizens has been vaccinated
um is the commission going to set a new
goal now or
and if not why not
in hindsight was it wise to to set this
goal of 70
back in spring
thank you um
i think that it's abundantly clear
that when the health crisis
was in full swing
at the beginning of the year
the
intent
was to ensure
that we would
explain
very clearly to everyone
that massive vaccination was a must
if we wanted to have a chance of
of coming through this crisis
and therefore setting an objective
focused people's attention
um
it showed that
we were ambitious in terms of delivering
great doses of vaccines to europe and
therefore
it spurred action from all the actors
involved and therefore i think that that
approach has been completely vindicated
the exact percentage
that
that was set at the time was based on
the information available at the time
and i think that with hindsight there
are many things that you can do
and but what is clear is that we have
always said
that we would be very attentive to the
evolutions in the epidemiological
situation
in the pandemic
in the
appearance of variants but at the time
nobody could predict how things would
evolve it is clear today
that um 70
the 70 threshold is definitely a major
achievement but that more needs to be
done
and and therefore that is what we are
now focused on and this is something we
have recognized already a long time ago
since you will remember
that
well before the summer we already
announced that we had signed a
supplementary contract
um with biotech pfizer for the delivery
of a significant number of new doses 1.8
billion in order to continue the
vaccination campaign taking into account
a whole series of needs
be it vaccinating new age categories
within the european population be it
the possible need for booster shots uh
et cetera et cetera so you know we've
always been i think at the same time
very ambitious
but very modest in saying this is based
on what we understand for the moment and
of course we will continue to adapt our
strategy as the situation evolves but
you see the result today
today the result is that
the european union is
one of the
places on earth if i can say where the
vaccination rates are the highest of
course we have issues as have been
highlighted now
of differences in vaccination rates
between countries
but
it is still an extremely significant
success to have reached um in basically
eight months
the um the vaccination reach uh the
vaccination rate that we have reached um
in uh in an eu of 450 million
inhabitants so we are extremely
satisfied by the progress that has been
made but our intent on ensuring that we
continue the efforts as long as required
any other questions for us today on this
that is not the case on other issues
i see no further hand raise so thank you
very much and we will meet again
tomorrow
for the next day briefing
you